alright so as many of you have noticed
i've been absent from youtube in the
last month or so and unfortunately i did
come down with kovid it took a lot of
energy out of me there were a few weeks
where i just did not have energy to do
anything
apart from growing a beard
but
thankfully i am more energized i've been
streaming the last couple days on twitch
and i finally have some energy and
motivation to make some new videos as
well
so in this video i want to share a game
i played on live stream yesterday that i
think offers a really nice metaphor
for when you're in a crummy situation in
chess or in life sometimes you just have
to keep surviving keep believing in
yourself
and eventually things will turn around
so i do hope you enjoy the video stay
tuned for more content i will be posting
more in the coming days and weeks
and uh yeah enjoy
okay
so i'm playing uh england again
i've started playing kind of this new
ish line
points not uh accepting though
um
this is not of a like appropriate or
responsible way of playing chess
but it's interesting like if h3 i'm like
already close to winning
if not h3 then i'm probably just worse
c6 i do this
um unfortunately there's not much there
okay so i haven't followed too many
opening principles
i'm moving the same piece place putting
them on the edge so happy to see you
streaming again
oh thank you nervy
yeah it is nice to be back
i have definitely missed streaming for
uh for a while now
okay i gotta focus
i have a lot of work to do for this
position
b3 may be coming
[Music]
i do have squares to work with
opponent wants to hurt me though
i could probably end up ooh i can't
castle
it's a really good move too
yeah now in a fun position
trying to hold on like rictia coming
[Music]
wow
[Music]
how bad is this
this is absolutely terrifying
um i mean there's so many discoveries
here
stop hurting me
it's so close to mating though
c3 king d3
that's a miracle i'm still alive
fighting bishop f4
i'll just pre-move that
welcome back eric
from quebec canada thanks for all the
amazing chess content good luck on the
final round of i'm not a g hi
how am i not dead
yet i'm gonna hide on each too
oh no time
let's go
was that game
that was a funny game
oh what a game
that's how you survive the worst
this was kind of like my experience with
kovid
i was getting like absolutely crushed
for a long time
but then i kept surviving surviving
surviving
and now i'm back baby